et reprend à l'avs est un jeune
chirurgien plein d'avenir
il est en train d'expérimenter une
nouvelle technique pour permettre de
dilater la rate des malades qui ont
l'estomac dans les talons sans comprimer
les of ages j'espère que cette opération
va réussir car elle permettrait de
sauver des milliers de vies humaines
toute la ville de bruit sur voir des
particulièrement geneviève la fouille
la ville est l'assistante du docteur m'a
lambert est en émoi je suis dans les
moins bons jours geneviève
comment allez vous bonjour docteur quel
plaisir de travailler avec lui
qu'il est beau et intelligent et bien
que six oreilles ne soit pas très propre
comme il est séduisant
passez-moi le bistouri
oui je suis follement amoureuse de lui
mais il ne s'en aperçoit pas car ils se
donnent 30 à son travail
je sais que mon assistante geneviève est
follement amoureuse de moi mais je ne
m'en aperçois pas car je me donne trop à
mon travail
peu après l'opération touche à sa fin il
ne me reste plus qu'à greffer l'oreille
gauche à l'orteil droit et ce sera un
franc succès quelques instants plus tard
bonjour bertrand philibert mon ami
d'enfance qui est devenu un avocat
renommé que fais tu là je passais te
féliciter pour son opération qui est un
franc succès dis moi tu as une nouvelle
assistante et les charpentes
oui elle est très efficace at-elle une
spécialité
elle est interne mais je ne m'en suis
pas rendu compte car je me donne tout
entier à mon travail j'aime gontran mon
amour pour lui n'a pas de bornes
je suis la seule qui sort elle aimait le
comprendre m'occuper de lui le chéri lui
nettoyer les oreilles
il faut que je la tire chez moi pour lui
avouer mon amour cherchant un prétexte
soudain ça y est j'ai trouvé
allô docteurs pour nous passer chez moi
j'ai acheté un couteau à éplucher les
pommes de terre je voudrais me montrer
ainsi il ne se méfiera pas vrai ciel
déjà lui bonjour geneviève alors c'est
épluchures de pommes de terre
il le voit la très jolie et comment ça
marche comme ça très intéressant et
encore comme ça passionnant et encore
comme ça
fabuleux je suis très content que vous
ayez acheté cet instrument au revoir je
n'y arriverai jamais eu dirai ce que
j'ai une maladie incurable
non car je ne veux pas de ça pythie et
soudain pendant ce temps là je lui tiens
plus
depuis que j'ai rencontré geneviève
jorat toutes les plaidoiries
je suis un avocat fini hélas elle n'a
d'yeux que pour mon ami contre je peux
tout de même pas le tuer c'est mon ami
d'enfance et sous 2 pendant ce temps là
tout d'un coup je deviens je meurs
d'abord pour vous il a l'air sincère
mais j'aime contre ans qui n'a guère à
une plus grosse paye veste et philibert
contre 1 est votre ami voyant je ne
voulais pas vous l'avouer mais je
souffre d'une maladie honteuse
non incurable
là par exemple moi aussi sapristi alors
avant que la mort de nos réunissent
jamais dans l'éternité
profitons de la vie montrez-moi votre
culotte
ciel philibert que vous y allez montrer
votre ami voyant votre ange l'emmerdent
jeu depuis que de quoi vivre je veux me
marier avec vous faire des enfants avec
vous achetez de bil'in crédit avec vous
tiens ils sont moins forts des oreilles
que grand train soudain pendant ce temps
là tout à coup pour risques m'en tiens
philibert mon vieil ami d'enfance qui
est maintenant un avocat renommé
geneviève mon infirmière qui m'aime mais
je ne m'en aperçois pas car je me donne
trois mon travail que faites vous là
gontran j'aime geneviève comment s'en
est trop ciel s'écroule pour moi vous
m'aimez dont contre n'ont pas vous non
c'est toi philibert que j'aime depuis
toujours ou autre en vous ne voulez pas
être à moi philibert ne sera pas à vous
car nous sommes atteints d'une maladie
incurable et mystérieuse et nous
mourrons ensemble
et bien non car mois contre an mal an
baer jeune chirurgien plein d'avenir
qu'il donne trop à son travail
je viens de découvrir un vaccin unique
au monde qui va vous guérir tous les
deux
et toi philibert tu seras à moi montrant
m me libère gilbert lenne geneviève
geneviève m gondrand
nos héros avec vont-ils à s'extirper de
ce grade cruel le vaccin du docteur m'a
lambert existe-t-il vraiment vous le
saurez dans le prochain épisode de notre
grand roman photo geneviève la fouille
est infirmière diplômée d'état et pas
fier la semaine prochaine dans nous
trois